good okay my name is Jerry Blumenfeld
I'm the secretary of the California
Environmental Protection Agency we're
here not for great news but for news
that you're gonna hear California again
is having to fight back so to start up
we have the Attorney General from the
great state of California
have you ever Sarah secretary thank you
very much thank you all for being with
us I wish I could tell you this is new
news but it's it's a regurgitation in
many ways of something we've been
hearing for over a year I'm pleased to
be joined obviously by governor Newsom
we have our carb Chair Mary Nichols who
has been a champion on these issues for
for a long time and we're thrilled that
she's here in the secretary thank you
for also being part of this announcement
California has always been a state that
leans forward we've been setting the
pace in so many ways for so many years
here in America when it comes to auto
emissions we know we have to get moving
to address the dire air pollution issues
in our state it's not a choice for us
there are more than 35 million cars
trucks and other vehicles that are
registered here in our state of
California that's more than any other
state and those cars and trucks here in
our state and across the country are the
nation's largest contributors to
greenhouse gas emissions transportation
alone in our state is responsible for 29
percent of all greenhouse gases we're
already seeing the way greenhouse gases
and climate change are affecting our
state from wildfires and droughts to
super storms floods and mudslides these
changes affect not just our environment
but our economy and our health
California's leadership and expertise
and the presence of serious air
pollution concerns in our state are
among the reasons why Congress granted
our state the authority to combat our
air pollution by setting our own
standards for vehicle emissions way back
I want to be clear every time California
sets a new air pollution rule
new motor vehicles we have to get a
waiver from the EPA every time since
governor not Newsome governor Ronald
Reagan was in office we've had approvals
and since the creation of the Air
Resources Board itself California has
been seeking waivers we've been granted
100 waivers never has one been rejected
that's 50 years of receiving waivers
thanks to the state's regulations
written under these federal waivers
California has seen reductions of some
400,000 tons of emissions per year
between 1970 and 2010 California
standards have encouraged the
development of critical emissions
control technologies many of which have
been deployed nationally not just in our
state some of California's standards
alone led to stronger standards from the
EPA itself all of this ultimately
leading to cleaner cars and cleaner air
for all Americans
it's clear that this is the direction we
need to move in it's clear that the
stakes are high for California it's
clear to consumers across the country
and it's clear even to automakers who
are embracing cleaner cars as president
Trump arrives in California taarakian
campaign cash his administration is
preparing to announce his desperate plan
to rob our state of it's long-standing
authority to set vehicle emissions
standards the president just tweeted
about it a few minutes ago our message
to those who claim to support states
rights don't trample on ours doing so
would be an attempt to undo the progress
we've made over the past decades we
can't afford that here in California we
cannot afford to backslide in our battle
against climate change for us this is
about survival our communities are
screaming for help to address the
climate crisis unlike the trump
administration we don't run scared and
so whether it is
climate change or an administration
recalcitrant and taking on its
responsibilities we're prepared to lead
we'll prepare to fight we'll do what we
must with that let me now turn it over
to the carb Board of Directors chair
Mary Newton
thank you and good morning everybody I
have a very heavy heart this morning you
mentioned that I've been working this
topic for a long time now I had the
privilege of serving at the
Environmental Protection Agency under
President Clinton at the time when
California first adopted the zero
emission vehicle program and the EPA
found a way eventually to approve that
over the objections of the auto industry
I might add some things have changed
since then even though every governor of
California has had to go back and to
confront EPA sometimes more or less
success to push them to allow California
to move ahead
it hasn't been always an easy and
unbroken path but the fact is that we
are now in a situation where we are
attempting to enforce standards that
were developed in collaboration with not
only the last administration the Obama
administration but with the auto
industry and the jobs that the president
is tweeting about this morning are all
now moving in the direction of electric
vehicles the people at General Motors
who he claims to care about who are
moving on into new careers they are
moving into electric vehicles because
that company is now shifting all of
their production into electric vehicles
so to be faced with a situation where
the EPA is claiming that they now no
longer can allow us to have a waiver
which is already in existence is a
particularly ironic situation this has
never happened before EPA has sometimes
stalled we've sometimes had to push we
once went to court but we have never
a situation where there was suddenly a
change of mind about what to do so I
think there's no question of course that
we will be in court as soon as we have a
document actually out there maybe even
ahead of that and I asked the Attorney
General on the way in if since I in fact
have been paying my bar dues all these
years just in readiness for this moment
he would allow me to sign on to the
litigation and he said he would find a
way to do that this is the fight of a
lifetime for us we have to win this and
I believe we will in this battle of
course we are led by our governor who
has shown himself to be a worthy
champion for the cause of clean air and
climate change and who has not only
backed us but has pushed us every step
of the way to do more so governor Newsom
it's yours I want to I want to pick up
on the note of optimism we will prevail
this was a move you know demonstrable
move sir power and dominance aggressive
move against the state a few days before
UN climate week to punctuate a point and
and it's a point that's been advanced by
previous administrations let's not
forget we were here just a few years
back George W Bush asserted the same
kind of authority at least tried to
assert that they had the ability to
eliminate our waiver a waiver that goes
back to my birth year in 1967 when we
had major smog in Southern California
and you had a leader an environmental
leader by modern terms in the name of
Ronald Reagan who pushed the federal
government eventually leading to the
Clean Air Act signed by again a
Republican environmental leader by
modern Republican standards by the name
of Richard Nixon this is bipartisan you
know senator senator Murphy a Republican
at the time in California was also
advocating for the same I don't know
what the hell has happened to the
Republican Party by the way where is the
Republican Party right now
where are they pushing back why aren't
they pushing back they believe in
federalism they believe in state rights
at least they assert that and nowhere to
be found
100 waivers have been approved over and
over and over again courts have upheld
our rights of these waivers so I'm
confident we'll prevail eventually we'll
take years and years and years more
uncertainty more anxiety but California
will prevail because we're leaders in
this space and the spirit of Jerry Brown
I can't imagine wants to be in Colusa
rather we standing here at this podium
at this moment let me quote Pericles who
said we do not imitate for we are a
model to others former mayor Pericles
told that to the Athenians we are the
pace car as it relates to environmental
stewardship clean air clean water and
reducing tailpipe emissions and so we're
proud of that it's part of who we are
it's in our DNA and it's part of our
economic story and I want to just close
on this we are also dealing with an
administration that lays claim in a
Republican part of the lays claim to
supporting free enterprise the irony of
that shouldn't be lost on anyone when
they called in these same companies and
threatened their business models and
have now asserted under antitrust
provisions they have set the DOJ as a
political arm in the administration to
further threaten and chill our
negotiations with additional companies
that were very soon about to join
voluntarily California's higher vehicle
emissions standards that's not free
enterprise that's not about states
rights
that's about bullying and intimidation
that's unethical I would argue margin on
the margin illegal but that's the four
folks that went to law school I did not
and in so California will assert itself
all just close on this I you know it's
this is not surprising as Mary said I
said I think we've been thinking about
this I think the day he got in office we
anticipated this move but I find it so
fascinating that we didn't think it
would be his first move on the issue of
tailpipe emissions we thought he would
go after
our fuel standards that have now been
adopted by the Obama administration and
the law of the land and it's interesting
they can't even fake the science they're
so desperately flailing they seem they
can't even figure out the data the
science in an irony of ironies and I
think one of you picked this up if they
possibly were successful with a waiver
but not with a vehicle miles to
Henderson the irony is the default would
be back to the Obama standards not to
the new negotiated standards with the
automobile companies that they claim to
be protecting that were agreed to in our
pact
that's the perversion of this moment
pure politics and politics that could
have profound consequences not just
terms the air we breathe in the state of
California and addressing the fact we
still lead the nation in air pollution
seven of the top ten cities most
polluted cities in America are in our
state that's why this is so important
but will impact the rest of the country
and enclosing the rest of the world the
innovation genies out of the bottle
every single one of these companies know
where the consumers going know where the
world is going they know where China has
committed to going to by 2040 they know
where India and Japan are going and
that's the elimination of the internal
combustion engine every one of these
automobile manufacturers has to compete
not just domestically but globally they
cannot compete unless they meet and
anticipate the needs and meet the
direction the rest of the world is going
California gets that because we're in
the future business and that's why they
voluntarily agreed to our standards
because they know that's where the
consumers are going and the markets
going and the rest of the world is going
so it begs the question mr. Trump what
and who is this for the companies the
automobile manufacturers don't want it
so is it about marathon petroleum look
them up because it is it's about you
know Charles cokes
efforts to manipulate and to market
efforts to advance this announcement
it's about the oil industry . . it's not
about the car manufacturers not about
consumers it's not about the health it's
not about our economy it's about oil
companies and our any of that final
words is here we are the precipice of
more unrest in the Middle East a time
when we've yet again been exposed for
our deep dependence on foreign oil that
now has a trajectory to get us back into
conflict in the Middle East our foreign
policy our treasury
our moral authority around the world all
dependent upon fossil fuel industry
whose time is limited and is coming to
an end in California once to make sure
that we're on the right side of this
hinge moment in world history not just
California in American history so I
applaud the Attorney General and just
cannot say enough about the one and only
Mary Nichols for her extraordinary
talent and tenacity to do the right
thing we will prevail
we'll take any questions let me say a
couple words in Spanish cuz I know I'll
be asked and then we'll take some
questions real quickly
Oh UNCA Mose que el mismo dia que el
Presidente Trump piensa venir acalypha
california para sacar dinero politico de
nuestro estado no le vamos affirmative
Sekar each ATAR knows la torre dad de
prata hair el medio ambiente de limpiar
el RA a quien California yo ammos a
tomar todo lack Co necesaria para
asegurar lay a cualquier persona que
viven nuestro estado de que nosotros
aquí que Ramon limpiar el era el agua
que vamos que depend hemos en cada dia y
no importa lo que quiere hacer el
Presidente Oh lo que diga and soos
tweeds nosotros estamos listos de prata
hair al pueblo de california yo ESO
Strom Ozaki parados
feed mise en nuestro obligación de
contestar
a los votantes contest our al Pueblo
Presidente de California no UN
Presidente que quiero otra vez y ol r la
ley in cambiar la ley ot questions
Buono el anuncio viene sólo tenemos
tweets it twist no son oficial bueno tal
vez en este esta ministration see si
trabajan como lay oh lo piensa Dano Tron
pero lo que sabemos es que la
ministration esta pensando Naggar leia
california la torre da de a tenido por
uno cincuenta knows de tratar de
controller la pollution en nuestro
estado y nosotros no podemos permit
IRA's por que sabemos que nuestros hijos
dependent en una ear que pueden respira
y hace que para nosotros esto es algo
que tenemos que hacer y el presidente
trata de qatar knows es ahora dad deport
a her a nuestra nuestros Pablo our mo lo
lo necesario no trato de eliminar lo que
hace don't roam de stake Simoes Kashia
yeah
well let me just sum it up by saying he
doesn't have the executive authority to
do this he's going about it the wrong
way and we think that we can prove under
the existing law whether it's
environmental statutes have been around
for a long time or based on his constant
violation of the stat of the
Constitution that this type of action
won't stand there is a process by which
our governments are required a due
process under which our governments are
supposed to act to try to deprive our
people of their rights and certainly
under the Tenth Amendment the states
have rights as well and so we're gonna
do what we must to protect the rights
that we've had for some 50 years
well why don't we wait to see what
they're actually going to do before we
tell you how we're going to respond but
we're hearing obviously a number of
things and we're prepared to defend what
we and the federal government have been
doing for over 50 some 50 years and
correct me if I'm wrong but I think
there was a dedication in 2007 in
multiple cases we went to federal court
that were rejected so there's also
precedent here legal precedent and their
arguments made then
in the next few weeks it just depends on
what they do yeah and Mary I don't know
if you want to add anything well what
we've heard from mr. wheeler is that
they're trying to muddy the waters well
first of all they're blaming the press
actually for the waters but getting
beyond that that what they're saying is
what they're not going to interfere with
our Public Health Authority to set
standards only with climate change and
the reason why we can't set climate
change standards or greenhouse gas
standards because is because that
interferes with the Department of
Transportation is right to set the fuel
economy standards under cafe that issue
as the governor said has been litigated
twice now we don't think it's a winning
issue but even more importantly on a
factual basis you can't separate these
two things the standards that we are now
in the process of enforcing are
necessary to protect the public health
and welfare not just because we care
about the future of the planet or polar
bears it's because we actually need
these extra clean cars in order to meet
the health standards that are set by the
federal government that we violate now
on a very regular basis throughout
Southern California and the San Joaquin
Valley
if this prevails if it were to prevail
because I don't believe it well millions
of people in California and other states
that follow our standards will be
breathing dirtier air they will suffer
from more pollution more asthma cases
more hospitalizations more premature
deaths because the Trump administration
is going to try to pull back on the
current standards
well we're in a different world now you
know I I don't want to talk about the
state of discussions that we had with
individual companies
nobody has changed their positions from
where they were in a formal sense so the
four companies that signed signed the
agreement other companies have told us
that they were considering about two
wanted to but we're not having any
discussions right now because frankly
this new situation causes everybody to
step back and say what do we do now and
in the case of California we're telling
you what we're what we're doing now they
were threatened directly threatened
threatened directly by the Trump
administration threatened I don't think
this know this from conversations I have
a number of the CEOs that's the state of
America in 2019 president united states
and his surrogates threatening private
enterprise to do what they think is
right to meet the needs of their
customers that also has the benefit of
improving health safety and fuel economy
of millions of millions of Americans
that's a remarkable statement and of
itself the problem is that saving will
be lost in this afternoon's tweet as we
rush Zig to zag to keep up with this guy
but it is an extraordinary thing and
here's also what's extraordinary that
these companies have to make a decision
very soon they're making commitments to
new model years going out 20 21 22 23 24
they have to make commitments now which
standards are they going to meet are
they going to volunteer agree to the
higher standards ones that were advanced
by the bomb administration or wait for
years and years of uncertainty and
litigation I think they have no choice
but to do the right thing and I think
that's what's leading to the president's
unique frustration with California
because we are outsized in terms of our
influence and this is a point of real
deep frustration for
I think the oil industry is wanting to
get rid of this waiver for years and
years and it again predates President
Trump I think we can over play this
waiver specifically as an action that's
unique to the relationship between the
state and the administration it's just
one of many examples of that
relationship but I think one can over
state it as this waiver again was
attacked by george w bush administration
and we have predicted this day for many
many years since inauguration so in that
respect I think one should be cautious
about over hyping this particular act
but the sum total the aggregate cannot
be overhyped it is pretty clear that the
to the state and this administration do
not see eye on not just environmental
issues but immigration issues health
issues and a myriad of other issues
which our Attorney General is led
Oh long tweet well you don't give those
tweets
in the state by the way it's 40 40 41
percent of you consider the totality of
the transportation sector with the
Attorney General's referencing
specifically cars but you look at
airplanes and other emissions Mary
correct it's a little over for you yeah
in the nation it's a little lower by the
way that's why this is the game changer
you can't get serious about climate
change unless you're serious about
vehicle emissions you're not serious
about addressing the issues of climate
change unless you're in this space this
is big
everything else is relatively small this
is the game changer and so for all those
kids that are testifying today on
Capitol Hill focused on this issue focus
on at this moment this is such a pivotal
moment in the history of the climate
change debate again not just in
California America but our leadership
and influence around the rest of the
world
that's why I'm good Mary said here with
a heavy heart she means that and why she
says she wants to be attached by name to
this effort she means that because this
is a legacy moment it is of that
consequence
how many 30 some-odd many people have
years
people are buying
the industry has been turning out new
electrified models at a pace that's
never been seen before including trucks
now because they concede that they can
market these vehicles worldwide in
places where the price of gasoline is
really prohibitive and also that
customers by the way don't mind having a
better fuel economy if they get all the
other virtues that they want and
electric vehicles are fun to drive
people actually like them because they
have a lot of power and pick up and you
can speed away from red lights and all
of that so hey I'm I'm I'm a free-market
guy why do these companies voluntarily
agree because they know it's where the
consumers going and they recognize the
fuel efficiency is the differentiator
the cost of fuel will more than offset
any costs associated with improving
technology but the improved technology
is also a competitive advantage in terms
of your market share and your ability to
compete for consumers that are looking
for the latest technology and efficiency
and experience so that's the most
specious argument of the lot
particularly at a time when oil hit
yesterday 62 dollars in 10 cents I did
not check the price of crude this
morning
check the numbers
don't just buy it
speaking to the mic yeah
[Music]
it doesn't set new standards it simply
tries to rip away authority that
California has by the way if those if
the arguments in the president's tweets
are the arguments they would use to
propel this initiative then we're we're
looking pretty good yeah and we'll and
we'll enjoy facing them in court if
that's the that's the argument they're
gonna make we'd love to see them put
this the facts in the science together
and that's perhaps why they've taken so
long to issue something they've been
saying forever that they were going to
do is they can't find a way to square
the facts and the science with what
they're trying to do let's do this hold
that question let's take all the
questions on this particular issue first
okay if it's gonna relate it to this
room back to the point is solution in
search of a problem
what does it do that we're not doing
well I appreciated your article this
morning and I appreciate you were gonna
be working on a new article Friday when
we make some announcements
did I say that yeah it was yesterday
you gotta ask him I don't look I I as I
said I just don't wake up with a
clenched fist every morning I don't I
want to work with the president I want
to work with our merger declarations
debris removal and disaster recovery I
want to work with him on resiliency
broadly defined I want to work with him
on getting rid of flavored cigarettes I
want to work with him on a myriad of
issues getting prescription drugs down
and his alleged commitment to
infrastructure but in the absence of
that we're gonna push back when he tries
to go after our dreamers and go after
you know access to reproductive rights
and go after our diverse communities and
you know I we're gonna have the backs of
people the state and our values and no
way I don't think the Attorney General
wakes up looking for a lawsuit but vast
majority these were reacting to the
assault in this state and so it's it's
an unfortunate relationship but the good
news we got a great legal mind here and
a legal team and we're winning and
that's the frustration he's having we
aren't winning
he's losing and we're winning because we
have the law science and facts on our
side and we have not only the formal
Authority we have the moral authority
and that is something missing in this
White House
yeah okay just one link question so I
waited say goodbye to Mary and Garrett
and the governor
you know the answer here we don't
generally discuss any legal actions that
we might take any investigations that we
may be undertaking as well and so you'll
have to stay tuned certainly we
understand the issue of homelessness
we've worked with the legislature and
the governor on issues of homelessness
where we can and will make sure that
we're on top of it because it is a
crucial issue that we must solve here in
California but I can't get into any
specifics about any kind of legal action
we might be taking thank you thanks
everyone
oh did you ask well that's passion yes
I'd say that for those who have some
question did they know that we were
going to take on the largest health
largest healthcare system in Northern
California in its continued
consolidation of the infrastructure in
health care to the point where we ledge
that it has cost northern Californians
thousands of dollars more to get health
care here than in Southern California
for the same services our lawsuit
against Sutter Health is based on
antitrust violations did Californians
where Californians aware that we were
going to sue one of the largest oil
companies in America Valero for trying
to consolidate in the distribution of
the very petroleum that they refine in
which case they would allow them to own
the spigot and control the spigot on how
Californians get their gasoline we took
on Valero then and we won but no one
knew about that did people know we were
in a protracted investigation of and a
successful culmination of the case
against Equifax for its breach private
information I could go on and on and we
don't discuss for good reasons any
investigations we might undertake
because we want to make sure that we
optimize the opportunity to succeed
where appropriate we will opioids
everyone knows that virtually every
state is involved in action it's not
because California disclosed it it's
because others did and of course it was
it became apparent to California was
part of that investigation and by the
way I would say I would submit to you
that because so much was being aired
publicly and also being leaked you now
have a situation when where many of the
plaintiffs including virtually every
state have now taken different positions
on how to settle the opioid crisis with
regard to Purdue Pharma
and that's unfortunate because I think
it would have been best if all the
plaintiffs were speaking with one voice
many of us are moving forward opposed to
the suppose the purported settlement
which is worth far less than Purdue
Pharma would like people to believe but
it doesn't help when information is
leaked out that doesn't help you
progress and in in our state of
California we try to make sure that the
first thing that we care about the
priority for us is winning if we're
going to investigate and prosecute thank
you okay have a great day